[Music]
hi
everybody and welcome back i'm james
powell i serve as co-chair of the num
focus board
together with dr lorena barba and i also
serve as vice president
of pi data as vice president of pi data
i have purview
over all pi data meetups and conferences
worldwide
it is my absolute pleasure to bring you
this
discussion with michael karnick vp of
product development from blue yonder
as part of pi data global we wanted to
reach out to each one of our sponsors
and give them a moment to talk about why
they use python why they're invested in
the pi data stack
why it is that they've chosen to give
back not only to pi data
not only to num focus but to the broader
open source ecosystem and community
hi pi data community uh i'm michael
i'm vice president product development
at blyonde
i got a phd in physics but i really love
love coding and i started
using python a couple of years ago and i
really enjoy
coding python even though today i'm a
manager and
i'm more into excel blue yonder is a
company that's
working on the autonomous supply chain
that means
making decisions every day what kind of
products
to produce to transport where
to put it into the stores with ideal
quantities so that we can eliminate food
waste
for the planet and deliver great value
to the customers
is blue under hiring in what roles and
in what regions
blue yonder is always hiring um and the
roles they range from
from software engineers data scientists
non-technical roles in around you know
marketing
management also tech management
obviously
and you can find us basically around the
globe in the u.s
at dallas for example or at scottsdale
um in monterey in mexico you can find us
in europe in the uk and in germany
we have a great presence in india as
well so basically wherever you are it's
possible to work for bleon
how long have you been vp of product at
blinder
um so i've been vp for about two years
and before that i i spent around six
years being
being a software engineer and one more
year
being an entry level manager what is
your favorite
community driven open source project
what excites you
the most about recent developments in
the pi data stack so i think my
my favorite project that we use
would be would be dusk um
because you know it it brings pandas to
to the next level to the next scale
and no longer limited by just just a
notebook or a really big machine
that's really expensive on on the cloud
provider of your choice
and it makes um you know it still makes
all the data accessible
you know through through a jupiter
notebook which is which is really
convenient
um i i think it should be used more um
and i think we're one of the of the
power users of the of task and
really getting the system uh to to its
extremes
and um you know challenging stability
and and performance
and you know it's also nice to uh to
engage with
with the authors of that one and we've
made some some contributions to
uh to that one so tell me which blue
yonder supported
open source project are you most proud
of which project do you think will have
the most
impact on the industry so um
referring to to my earlier answer that i
think this
you know scale out will be important um
i would say car to take
is like the most the most interesting
one because it tries to solve
the problem how can i maintain large
tabular data
with very reasonable costs in a cloud
infrastructure
while still being able to you know to
manage consistency
um of of your data set so it
provides you with with easy access on
multiple
cloud stores i think that's that's
really cool um
and to see how it will will interact
with the other tools in the in the
environment
um and uh so so that's that's one
um the other one is turbo dpc which
is um an odbc bridge uh for
for python so you can basically use it
with any database that
provides an odbc driver and odbc is not
like
like the the selling point but it's
attempting to use
binary data in the inside and trying to
expose the binary data
to python users as numpy arrays and
empire arrow tables michael i'm really
glad that we had this opportunity to do
this profile of blue yonder
i know blue yonder i know blue under his
name since you've been a regular
committed sponsor of other pi data
conferences such as pi data berlin
i think people would like to know what
drives blue yonder's commitment
consistent commitment to supporting the
open source ecosystem and to supporting
specifically pi data and num
so i think it's um it's the people at
blue yonder who
who drives us first and foremost um
the you know the engineers that we have
then they're passionate about the craft
they are passionate about the tools that
they use
and they they also like to share you
know many of us have
a background from university um we have
both
collaboration and and competition and
it's similar in the open source uh
community you know everybody is helping
out each other but still there's
there's some projects doing the same
things so it's it's friendly competition
and when you go to conference
uh in the open source community it's
very similar than you know
to to going to um to a scientific
conference
so that's nice and um we value that we
can
constantly exchange with with experts in
the fields
um we know that there's people out there
who can build the software that we need
much better than we can do uh on you
know
on a non-uh core business domain at
least
um we we like that we can you know give
something back to the community and
you know it's it's not about just just
taking and saying as free lunch
now we also give give back we we
contribute patches we contribute some
some open source tools ourselves and um
it's also a great way to you know to to
showcase our engineers
when when they have like a significant
portfolio
uh when you can look up their their
videos on youtube when they spoke at
uh at pycon germany for example and so
that's that's really fun to see and uh
in the past we've um we've also
took great time um and put it into
organizing conferences so pycon germany
2017 and 2018
um has been co-organized by by
some of the people who work for me um we
we usually or we often host
um meetups in around data science or
python topics
we provide our office locations and uh
make sure there's sufficient beer and
and pizza um and that's you know it's
it's just sometimes it's the highlight
of the week really
when you go to such meetup and and you
engage with other engineers and
you have you have a contact to the
technology
that's that that's really nice and it
never gets old and it
you know personally i know that working
on open source projects can be really
rewarding
um you know and if you if you look at
at github and you see that people are
actually using what what you coded
that's nice that's that's that's really
engaging and motivating
and that's how we like our engine is to
be engaged and motivated and open source
is
one of the best ways to achieve that
understanding that you know choice of
language and choice of tools can be very
specific i want to hear a little bit
about why
you chose python and how that's worked
out for you what
excites you about the python community
what specifically excites you about
python's use for data engineering and
data science
that's a really good question and i'm
i'm very glad that this is a virtual
forum
because i have to confess that
originally i didn't like python at all
and uh i was more of a c plus plus guy
you know
you have those types you have those
compilers and they protect you
at least that's that's what i thought in
the beginning um but as a company um we
realized
um in in in 2012 2013
that it's not easy to get um developers
really productive with c plus plus we
we took a look at python during the time
frame 2012
2013 uh when it was not like the most
hyped language on the planet
and we found that it's it's really great
because
you the the syntax is really nice easy
to pick up
you can write glue code without thinking
too much
it's not that bad if you have you know
a dynamic type system and duct typing it
actually
works and like the number one worry that
we had was performance
but at the time when we had looked at
python
we already had you know numpy and and
pandas and and that basically solved the
problem
so it doesn't really matter if the glue
code is running slow
when the glue code is you know just 20
operations
and the whole mathematical things
in the background are some optimized c
library
and and that really boosted the data
science that we could do
i think at the time it was a gamble and
the python community really delivered
and we never looked back this was
excellent decision for us
in terms of room for improvement or room
for growth
what pain points do you have in your
stack are there any things that
you wish the python community might
focus more on any issues that you feel
need a little bit more attention to suit
the needs of blue yonder
um so i i guess one of the
one of the key things that we that we
struggle with
is stability and performance
that can be a challenge this is not
something that is that is intrinsic to
to python or any of the open source
projects
it's just um that sometimes the degree
at which we use these
projects is not what what the original
authors intended so we're really
pressing things
um against the limits and and sometimes
beyond that
the second thing um i guess where we
sometimes struggle with python
is um there is many competing things and
competing standards also in in terms of
uh types so you know uh previous version
of of pandas they
they did not really have um nullable
types
in in a way that um that you would
probably design it today
and i think they're fixing that uh the
extension array
that's true and um there's there's many
conversions if you go from from one
library to
the others and they're not not always in
the compatible or
it just needs that extra conversion step
you know that is simple to write down
but still you have to think about it
michael is there anything you'd like to
say to the pi data global community
anything you'd like to share with them
about blue yonder
about pi data the community the
conference or about open source in
general
so if you're watching this video i think
you're doing many things right not
because you're watching me
but you're engaging with the community
so keep up that
great work uh keep on building your uh
your profile
um so that your that you remain
interesting for
uh for companies such as pre-owner
because we're always looking for
for experts and passionate people who
live and breathe coding every day
and who are open for uh for a technical
challenge so keep up the great work
keep on contributing it's amazing what
you do every day
also you know in your free time and
weekends with families really appreciate
that
and that's also why we're giving back
so thank you everybody for joining us
for this pie data global sponsor
interview
i'm james powell i want to thank michael
carnegie vice president of product
development from blue yonder for joining
us today really interesting to hear
about how blue yonder engages with the
open source community
this really is a model for how other
organizations
can make sure that they have their
impact felt but also
deliver things that are useful for them
internally
thank you so much michael and thank you
all for watching
thanks james for having me and enjoy the
[Music]
conference
you